welcome back to the ultimate
intellectual Arena face off exclusively
on the Michael Knowles show where modern
day Gladiators engage in a bragging
rights fight to the death on the topics
that truly matter I'm Ben Davies and I
am the guy who reads the cards today for
your five-time defending Champion your
host Michael Knowles it's great as
always to be introduced as the host of a
show by a guy who is sort of the host
but not I'm the host anyway and I'm here
to defend and protect my record when you
want to protect your home you got to
check out ring more from them later but
Ben
against whom am I competing well this
Challenger is the only man who has been
right about everything who has read
every book since he was alive to
proofread their work he is the sexy
Gandalf himself Andrew klavan oh thank
you Ben you know I hate people who make
excuses for these things but I do want
to say that I will be uh playing with an
open uh gunshot wound that I received
rescuing a child from gangsters and will
be going directly from here to the
hospital so Knowles beats me that may be
why maybe because I'm bleeding out so
that no absolutely fair and Ben I
believe the topic this time is riddles
yeah well with Michael being undefeated
and claven being a true master of words
poems and hidden meanings we are going
to engage in the classic battle of wits
this is face off riddle Edition
[Music]
just so you know you will have 20
seconds gentlemen 20 seconds to give
your answer you will have one reread so
we can get through all these are you
ready I guess I'm ready though Ben I
have to say this is not fair since Drew
actually was present when the Sphinx was
built and so has a very long-standing uh
relationship with riddles that is the
last riddle I've done so I'm out of
practice the first riddle what is always
in front of you but cannot be seen I'm
really torn between giving a real answer
and just a joke answer to every one of
these but I'll give the one that I think
is right as expected you guys Beat the
Clock what did you put Michael
the future
true uh it's the same thing as of
tomorrow
the correct answer is the future or
tomorrow congratulations gentlemen all
right the next one this is a little bit
longer I am something people love or
hate I change people's appearances and
thoughts if a person takes care of
themselves I will go even higher to some
people I will fool them to others I'm a
mystery some people might try to hide me
but I will always show no matter how
hard people try I will never go down
what am I
okay you guys can just show you these
are not very hard I'm going to say age
no that's what I said my age age is
correct yeah okay all right this is
great I I thought that these were going
to be very difficult riddles these are
instead little sort of jokes that they
tell you in kindergarten or something so
that's fine I'm just happy to survive I
I don't think well under pressure if I
if I played Jeopardy I would have to pay
them at the end of the show
all right we'll see if this gets a
little harder for you gentlemen if Apple
made a car what would it be missing gosh
I don't even have a joke answer we may
take the lead windows
it is in fact Windows
sexy Gandalf pulls ahead I hate that I
can fill a room or just one heart others
may have me but I cannot be shared what
am I
Michael you're starting to make me
nervous okay no I got this yeah
all right Drew let's show first I I
didn't I don't know I got I said love
but that doesn't sound right to me no I
I decided to go for a much um goryer
idea I can fill a room or just one heart
blood
I can fill a room full of blood the
correct answer is loneliness and this
riddle is actually from one of the
Batman comic books from the Riddler
well no wonder we couldn't help yeah do
we look like super villains to you
what rock group consists of four famous
men but none of them sing I don't even
have a joke I don't even I don't have an
answer okay well what do you have drew
what's your answer uh Mount Rushmore yes
it is Mount Rushmore oh I hate that I
thought it was like a classification of
rocks like granite or something I knew
if it was an actual rock group I
wouldn't know so gosh I'm gonna lose I'm
down by two how many questions are there
there are a few more I'm not going to
tell you exactly how many so we still
fight to the Finish okay next question
alive without breath cold as death never
thirsty ever drinking all in mail never
clinking do you have an answer Michael
like a baby I guess all right what do
you have
suit of armor
suits of armor clink
what do you have I had ice
the correct answer is a fish and that
was from The Hobbit
jrl Tolkien I couldn't make it through
the Hobbit I never made it through any
of those Tolkien books even though I'm
told they're very good I don't think it
was Yale reading anyway well the thing
is like those books are actually
supposed to be very good but I can't I
can't get into it they're so long and I
have to say that like I think that there
was something wrong with a guy who can
invent an entire civilization including
its language I think
all right next one
one night a king and queen get on a ship
charted for a far away land the next
morning the king and queen get off the
ship who is left on the ship
Drew is just an assassin right now yeah
throwing these answers down okay no I
think I know the answer
10 seconds
got it so the okay the king and queen
get on a ship for a far away land
and then they get off the ship so who's
left on the ship
okay I've got the answer all right
what's the answer uh everyone else
pretty solid
the night is left the night is left on
the ship one night a king and queen get
on a ship Michael
um to buy on Words yes it is we need to
we have a comeback here man loosen up a
bit well you know is this is this where
you calculate how many riddles there are
so he can catch up I mean yeah there are
not enough riddles in the world I think
unfortunately it will only increase my
uh the difference the discrepancy
between the two all right let's see if
we tied up the race with this one all
right it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it is denied it is violence you
may find
all right let's show Justice
Ah that's true that's better mine was
fate it is Justice all right finally oh
my gosh and that grief that was actually
from the new Batman movie from the
Riddler
um it can be cruel poetic or Blind
Justice
the answer is justice that was worth
three points you said wow okay wow it's
almost tied up yeah yeah a man and his
son crashed while driving down an icy
Road two ambulances came one took the
father to a hospital in the west the
other took the sun to a hospital in the
East nurses rushed the boy into surgery
and the doctor said I cannot operate on
this boy he is my son how can this be
hmm
time okay I'm almost finished writing
the sentence yeah you're transcribing
the whole riddle for us Drew what do you
have uh the doctors his mother
um that doesn't that doesn't make any
sense Drew so I I gave that answer as a
secondary answer but I said uh it's
because the doctor is the gay partner of
the injured dad assuming that no no
ladies or surgeons but I did say if the
feminists are right then it's the mom
but I I'm still going with my first
answer what does a liar do once he is
dead
time okay Drew uh lies still
Michael uh burn in hell
if he didn't repent before death
I wish I could accept that Michael but
it is in fact he lies still from also
from the Batman movie
pretty sure I'm right also but that's
fine
okay with the holidays coming around the
corner many of us will be traveling to
see our families and loved ones very
soon you may find yourself away from
home more often than not that is why I
have teamed up with a ring with ring
security products you can rest easy
knowing that your home and family are
safe when you are not there the ring
doorbell notifies you when guests or
packages arrive Rings indoor cameras let
you keep an eye on kids and pets while
you're away ring alarm will alert you of
any motion detection while the house is
empty plus if you add smart lighting
around your home you can turn lights on
or off while you're away Rings home
security products don't just help keep
your home and family safe they make
perfect gifts for everyone on your list
head on over to ring.com collections
slash offers to find out how you can
live a little less stressed this season
with a ring product that is right for
you that is ring.com slash collections
slash offers all right let's get back to
my being absolutely slashed to bits in
this awful competition all right here we
go
wait wait a minute when do we get the
last question we're very close to you
all right here we go I just need to
catch up first yeah exactly this is like
this is like Maricopa County okay we're
gonna keep doing these all night baby
it's gonna go through all weekends until
we get the answer anymore all right I
can sneak up on you or be right in front
of you without you knowing but when I
reveal myself you will never be the same
time
all right Michael what do you have I
said love or death hmm
Drew I I said an idea but I think really
it's the guy from Halloween probably you
were both incorrect the correct answer
is in fact betrayal the trail a trail
that what what's that from that's like I
think that was also one of the Riddler
Comics oh interesting did you read any
books for adults
never mind for adults there's any books
or any book yeah that's right a man
crossed the Rio Grande seeking
prosperity in a new land Democrats
called him racist for trying to join a
group from his homeland what is the name
of that group he crossed the Rio Grande
searching for opportunity in a new land
Drew Mexicans
I said the Ku Klux Klan because hear me
out it could have been a man crossing
the Rio Grande in the other direction
that's what I thought yeah and and that
and it would rhyme
wait a minute that makes no sense the
group the group The Man joined was the
KKK spelled
q-u-e-q-u-e-q-u-e so I will take the Ku
Klux okay great all right okay
I feel like I'm living in Philadelphia
at this point
all right all right here we go last
question
voiceless
it flutters toothlessed bites and
mouth-listed Mudders KKK yeah
all right Michael what do you have the
American electorate
Drew uh I said the wind it is the wind
mine was correct as well though was it
not do I get half a point it's voiceless
in Mexico or as they call it yeah okay
it can be carried but not touched it has
two on the outside and ten on the inside
everyone wants to catch a sight of this
but it is kept out of sight it was lost
and found and then found but now is lost
Michael what joke have you written down
uh the ark of the covenant it's not a
joke you heretic you sacrilegious
blaspheming pseudo host of this show
I was I was stumped I said a good name
but I don't know what the it is in fact
the Covenant
yeah Michael's in the comeback trailer
yeah this is great we only need to be
here for four more hours it's on my way
back yeah all things it devours Birds
beasts trees flowers it gnaws iron bites
Steel
grinds hard stones to meal it slays
Kings ruins towns and beats high
mountains down
what am I
pain in the ass
all right what do you got Michael time
I said the same thing it is in fact time
all right I thought that was going to be
my real chance I can't I cannot believe
this is still going on it's like a bad
dream
I take forever and I'm hosted by Ben
Davis
we're gonna move along here we only got
a couple more left and I think it is
tightening too Drew so we got to get
these last couple great here we go here
we go which word is spelled wrong in
every edition of the dictionary which
word is spelled wrong in every
edition of the dictionary I don't even
have a joke for this what do you have
drew uh wrong what did you say wrong
it's wrong
it's spelled wrong
I hate I hate riddles so much all right
here we go wait wait you said a couple
more so this is the longest one yeah
yeah this may be the last one yeah he
didn't yeah he didn't say only a couple
more though there's a couple more and
then a couple more I mean he's come out
from a Dominion voting machine so this
is gonna say you could be a poll Watcher
at this point only one color but not one
size stuck at the bottom yet easily
flies present in Sun but not in Rain
doing no harm and feeling no pain
what is it
time okay
Drew what do you have I had sunshine or
daylight
and I had whatever Drew said
so I think we both got it right the
correct answer is shadow shadow the one
time true thanks a lot yeah he was
totally wrong
even when I copy you even when I copy
the guy with the right answer I get it
wrong Drew Clavin is the champion of
this episode of Face-Off riddle Edition
To the victor goes to spoils Michael
will have to read a 30-second commercial
for why your show is awesome and why
people should watch it I don't want to
take this serious or anything
I'll tell you I and I said this going
into it I've done a bunch of these well
the winner and still king of Face-Off
Michael Knowles and I knew I knew with
every single one I was going to win I
want to at least be right in my
prediction of how wrong I would be I did
predict I said I'm gonna it doesn't
matter what topic I am going to lose to
Drew it's going to be humiliating and it
has been it has been humiliated I have
to agree with you on that I think you've
been utterly humiliated and then just he
brought down a little bit I think in
everybody's estimation yes yes we'll do
it now and put 30 seconds on the clock
that will start when you begin listen
folks if you want if you want all the
wisdom of my show if you want all the
incisive delightful and funny commentary
with uh none of the hair and
considerably more age and I'm sorry to
say perhaps some have said even more
wisdom you can tune into
the Andrew klavan show a show that is 97
as Catholic as mine
and much much less frequent
yeah I can't tell you how to I can't I
literally can't tell you what Dutch
Diane there aren't words small enough to
tell you how how touched I am
it's almost it's almost as if this
weren't worth it
maybe this will make it worth it for you
drew because I'm gonna tell the audience
if you haven't already please be sure to
get a copy of a strange habit of mine
the second book in the Cameron winter
mystery series available wherever books
are sold and please write in the
comments section and let us know who
you'd like to see and what topic you
want covered on the next episode of Face
Off
[Music]
thank you